of course he's an environmentalist and
the author of an editor of draw down the
most comprehensive plan ever proposed to
reverse global warming please welcome
Paul Hawken okay so we have had three
hurricanes now that have been pretty
disastrous so I thought it was a good
time to have someone who says they have
the most comprehensive plan to solve
global warming
tell metell us why your plan is
different and why it is the most
comprehensive well it's very different
because it's the first one ever actually
just go google it yourself there is no
plan to reverse global warming so we
were at ease when we said it was the
most comprehensive plan we could have
said the most literate or nuanced plan
because 40 years in to climate being in
the public sphere
there has been no plan to reverse global
warming and it's the only goal that
makes sense right now most of the
rhetoric is about slowing reducing
mitigation but if you're going down the
wrong road why would you want to slow
down you're still going down the wrong
road it's kind of like Thelma and Louise
and slow motion the only thing that
makes sense is to go back the way you
came right now the greenhouse gases we
are told are 407 ppm in the atmosphere
that is basically for its per million
parts per million excuse me a parts per
million 50% greater than it was in the
pre-industrial age but in fact if you
add the other greenhouse gases
nitrous oxide methane etc we're at 490
ppm and humanity in all its forms genus
Homo erectus fluorine thean Sesay pians
all those for too many years we've never
lived here when it's been over 300 ppm
until 1937 and now we've gone right by
300 and we're at 490 ppm and it doesn't
make sense to talk about stabilization
there is no stability at this so what's
the number there where we you know all
died we're at 490 you say we're at 490
yeah
what does it have to get to why go there
why can't I go the other way
you know I mean because really in a
sense that's why I go there no I don't
want to go there yeah I want to know how
close we are to the number but that's
really what the climate communication
the climate establishment is dynast
keeps scaring us keep you know so we
should be scared well on a scientific
point of view but once you have a
problem statement which is what the IPCC
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change is done it's a great problem
statement once you have hurricanes and
headlines that validate the problem
statement then let's pay attention to
the solutions and that's what we did a
project about it and you have no doubt
that the the weather in the 21st century
is partly caused by the global warm know
it down we're still getting the talking
points from the right wing you know what
wait yeah I know you're laughing and I'm
laughing but it's not funny because of
the 490 thing or whatever that number is
you would tell me I'm gonna get an idea
I want to know how much longer we have
you know you know they can always come
up with some thing about you know well
you know we haven't had a category three
hit the southern part of the country
since 1936
these still selling points it's silly
right I mean this has really happened it
is really the last three Harvey sixty
four inches in Jefferson County broke
the world record for rainfall okay then
irma the longest sustained category five
hurricane in history and then Maria in
Portland Co okay then we had two feet of
rain in 12 inches can you imagine
LA two feet away there's nowhere there's
nowhere for the water to go and so we
broke three records within 30 days and
people talking about this being a
weather event it's not a weather event
it's basically the the atmosphere giving
us feedback on what we've done down here
and we've got a reversal okay so in the
book it talks about seven different
categories places where this solution
can start to happen yeah
one of them is women yeah
why well let me let me step back a
little bit what we did is map measured
and modeled the hundred most substantive
solutions to global warming and when I
mean by solutions I mean things that are
at hand we know how to do it they're
scaling
ww grains or whatever these are things
that are in place and that we are doing
right now so that's what we modeled we
didn't model things we could do or ought
to do or should do and the number six
solution and we ranked them by impact in
terms of carbon all based on
peer-reviewed scientific literature by
the way none of the data Andrada is our
data the carbon is from science the
economic data is from respected
institutions like the World Bank the IEA
IPCC etc to the women well I get to the
winner always and we don't know how much
time we have left
exactly
[Music]
could be 491 yeah exactly so the number
six solution is educating girls and user
war does have to do with climate change
it has everything to do with population
and that is if you take girls out of
school which they are all over the world
to put their brothers through school for
early marriage child marriage those
women have an average of five on one's
religion likes to keep women in this
culture religion family universe
basically doing this again and again and
again but women can drive in Saudi
Arabia now yeah
my applause is sarcastic that's why I
didn't apply and if a girl is allowed to
stay in school supportive to stay in
school to say the equivalent of high
school she becomes a woman on her terms
and she plans her family because she
earns more money she's better educated
she puts those resources into her
children now write about women farmers
right yeah they're good at farming
we don't think of women as farmers Oh
40% of the farmers are women and they
are not in the world 40-bit Wow
yeah I didn't know that yeah and they're
less lucky to [ __ ] this you okay so all
right so let's quickly guess so another
another big thing that we can do we all
this is everybody's life every hour of
the day almost food waste yeah we waste
just a ridiculous amount it's the number
one thing individuals can do it stop
right it is number one it is number
three and overall impact that we don't
measure methane emissions from landfill
food to be even higher but food waste is
ubiquitous
everybody does it everywhere all the
time and they don't think about it in
developed countries because it's so
abundant whether it's at the restaurant
at home or when you're out or whatever
it is in the developing countries it's
the other way around poor people don't
waste food but it doesn't get to them
there's they lack cold chains here like
distribution or like good storage areas
so they lose it from the farm to the
city we lose it on the city or at the
store at the house or to the roaster
you're actually an optimist done this
though I mean III see that you think we
can innovate our way out yeah I get very
nervous when people say that because
then people get complacent so I want you
to tell us the truth
but please add don't get complacent
about it because I think people think ah
[ __ ] it you know we can do what we're
gonna do we aren't ailment Louie's we're
driving right toward the Grand Canyon
but somebody will come up with something
some big machine that will soak up all
the pollution what what is the
innovation that's gonna that's the
Silver Bullet mentality and it's corrupt
okay we're saying is we have 80
solutions we model with those we scale
that they're scaling we scale them over
30 years to see if we can achieve
drawdown reversal and 25 20 or 50 in
addition to that where we want people to
know is that humanity is on the case
humanity is brilliant inventive
ingenious and so we have 20 more coming
attractions yeah but those aren't the
people who control things they don't
need to be they do no they don't they
control ideas and imagination ideas
surpass corruption well that's a very
optimistic point of view our president
just pulled out of the Paris climate
Accord and he wants to build more cold
fountains so so it does matter who's in
charge so like all this stuff that we
can do it really has to all come down to
voting we look for love in all the wrong
places in terms of the present this
would be real what wingnuts have been
here for the last or we do we look I
mean we nuts have been leaders all
throughout history and they come and go
he made a hundred million people aware
with the Paris agreement who didn't know
about it so we have to give him credit
for that because by pulling out of it
you are
and then you had you had governors and
you had CEOs all over this country
saying we're gonna do it anyway so you
won't be but but nothing good it's not
optimistic it's really describing what
we're doing all right well my point of
view is it's my show nothing good is
gonna happen on this issue or any other
issue until the Democrats take over
Congress so and everybody should read
this one really you're gonna read a book
I've never said that on the job you're
gonna read one book read this one Thank
You doc I appreciate
[Applause]